buenas noches cómo están
para presentarme un poquito yo soy paula
soy artista también soy docente pero me
gusta más mi labor como artista
atrás por lo que vemos hizo unas
ilustraciones que en realidad siempre
dibujo para mí dibujar es como una forma
interpretar la vida así que para poder
hacer esta charla y poder tener un hilo
conductor un poco más amable para
ustedes porque el tema que traigo un
poquito áspero decidí hacer unos buenos
dibujitos bueno le digo bueno yo pero
está a criterio de ustedes juzgarlo para
que se pueda entender
ahí les presento a tres alumnos y un
televisor que fue un ejercicio que llevé
para hacer como ven
tenía mucho más alumnos en la clase pero
no iba a dibujarlos a todos porque eran
un montón y les quiero contar primero
una pequeña experiencia que tuve con
ellos preparé una película que duraba 7
minutos y la idea era poder usarla como
material base para después poder hacer
otro tipo de ejercicio era la clase de
animación
durante los siete minutos que tuvimos
para ver la película por ahí no era el
medio más cómodo porque en un televisor
grande no era una sala
mis alumnos revisaron sus celulares
constantemente
a mí se me prendió como la chispa pero
no de la felicidad sinceramente porque
me plantee como docente que estaba
pasando si yo estaba fracasando con el
material que había elegido o si
evidentemente no era algo apto para
ellos o si estaban en una sintonía que
evidentemente era otra
obviamente no dije nada deje que la
película termine les pregunté qué les
había parecido y la verdad que muchos no
contestaron
seguimos la clase y durante las seis
horas que yo tengo de viaje de esa
escuela es mi casa porque no queda la
misma ciudad
tuve una avalancha de preguntas y todas
esas preguntas en realidad me di cuenta
que en referencia a mí misma porque lo
que yo vi de mis alumnos era un acto
reflejo de lo que yo también hacía pero
no solo yo que hacemos todos y no nos
damos cuenta lo tenemos muy incorporado
y no lo vemos
al día siguiente bueno a ver si lo
puedes ver y me propuse contar durante
un día
cuántas veces revisaba yo mi celular sin
que tuviera una notificación sin que
hiciera un sonido
en un día común de laburo que laburo
horas corridas que voy a mi casa que
suena a veces a un teléfono otra cosa lo
realice 40 veces aproximadamente un par
que no conté ahora que antes
pero pues me puso a investigar y hay
gente que lo consulta a 150 veces sin
que haya hecho sonido
no les parece mucho ag pero sé que es
bastante
espera
[Música]
bueno hay tal perdón
me veo muy bien con la tecnología tan
pocas veces renueva bastante bueno una
de las tantas preguntas que yo me hice
es porque reviso tanto el teléfono
porque voy sí ya sé que no va a haber
nada es como cuando por inercia abro la
puerta de la heladera para ver qué hay y
ya sé que tengo lo mismo huevo la misma
leche las mismas cosas en el mismo lugar
durante toda la semana a menos que falte
básicamente hay una respuesta muy lógica
y que es bastante fea es que casi todas
las aplicaciones que están dentro de los
dispositivos que usamos están pensadas
para que la red las volvamos a mirar una
y otra vez
existe una forma técnica y científica
que han usado muchos y que ahora se ha
divulgado hace poco
para que todos estemos atentos buscan
estimular un neurotransmisor del placer
que tenemos todos obviamente y que se
llama dopamina para qué sirve para que
todo el tiempo cada vez que me des tu
teléfono sientas que está bueno y que
tenés que volver a hacerlo porque algo
te devuelve algo que es satisfactorio y
que te genera un estímulo positivo bueno
yo creo que quizás sea un error quizás
el estímulo positivo lo estamos
perdiendo de vista no es el que
realmente tenemos que ver
miren las tarjetitas para guiarme porque
obviamente estoy muy nerviosa lo claro
bueno en esta filmina siguiendo un poco
el hilo les planteo qué es lo que pasa
cuando exponemos a chicos muy pequeños a
ver muchas horas de televisión por
ejemplo
la mayoría de las veces creemos que
realmente están aprendiendo algo o que
están incorporando alguna situación
algún conocimiento en realidad cuando
exponemos a una persona muy pequeña a
muchas horas de televisión
esa persona sólo genera fascinación la
fascinación no es ningún procesamiento
cognitivo la fascinación es el estado de
embelesamiento sobre algo es algo que
nos obnubila que nos presta hermoso y
quedamos en boda decimos como cuando uno
se enamora de una persona y no sabes qué
decirle cuando te habla y quedas como
allí decía bueno algo así pero con las
pantallas
lo ideal hubiera sido que una persona
tenga un procesamiento de atención de
tensión sostenida que en el tiempo que
transcurre lo que está mirando pueda
realmente procesar lo que está viendo y
se pueda preguntar cosas y esas
preguntas les generen respuestas con
nuevas preguntas y así que empiezo un
ciclo de la duda permanente para que
para alimentar el cerebro el cerebro si
no se mueve se duerme
[Música]
bien bien bueno puede ser problema si yo
porque podemos decir bueno la
fascinación que tiene de malo realmente
que tiene mal lo que ellos me de tantas
horas de televisión tantas horas de
pantalla de computadora que cuál es el
problema de consumirla
es que todo lo que yo veo en esas
pantallas ya fue sumamente ingerido el
tiempo el minuto en el aire es sumamente
caro claro por una empresa entonces lo
que se pone ahí para que vos lo veas y
lo entiendas tiene que estar de forma
muy liviana por tanto el vocabulario que
vas a ver y todo el contenido no te está
aportando en ningún momento de reflexión
simplemente lo está absorbiendo porque
ya viene masticado
cuando uno no puede procesar y masticar
un conocimiento no incorpora vocabulario
si no incorporamos vocabulario pasa lo
peor
tenemos un empobrecimiento intelectual
significa que nos volvemos vulnerables a
cualquier decisión ajena y que tenemos
menos autonomía
[Música]
bueno justamente las pantallas estas a
las que tanto miramos los géneros la
posibilidad de tener un montón pero un
montón de actividades en el mismo tiempo
yo estoy segura que más de uno va al
baño con el celular y contesta mensajes
o llama a alguien estoy segura que
mientras escribe en un mail arma de un
playlist o mientras están cocinando al
mismo tiempo están realizando los
whatsapp es lógico yo lo hago y lo hacen
todos estoy segura pero me pregunto
cuánto de eso realmente es atención en
cada actividad y no eso si le hacíamos
cuando digo oscilar auxiliar significa
que es tengo un poquito acá que estoy un
poquito acá pero en realidad no estoy
ninguna de las dos
y eso genera un estrés mental y una
saturación que no nos damos cuenta hay
un momento donde generamos apatía a
todos donde golpe miro 200.000 series y
pasan los capítulos y bueno pasan ósea
pasó lo mismo con las historias que
pasan que por cierto eran 24 horas
porque evidentemente muy importante para
recordarlas no eran así que bueno pasan
pasa
todo este estrés es violencia hacia uno
mismo
es grave es realmente grave porque no lo
vemos es sumamente silencioso
toda esta sobreabundancia de datos de
alguna manera nos está sofocando pero
porque nos sofoca porque todas estas
redes sociales siempre nos acercan con
lo que está lejos pero lo inmediato y lo
que está cerca que pasa cuando tengo una
persona en frente estoy en un café
cuantas veces miro el celular y contestó
primero los mensajes si no la pregunta
que me he hecho
es fuerte me parece estamos perdiendo el
sentido sociabilización directo estamos
virtualizando a nuestras propias vidas
por ejemplo esto es un dibujito que hice
yo donde puse como referencia donde yo
vivo por ejemplo he visto un montón de
veces gente que sale a hacer deporte y
que pone a delante de esos niños en los
cochecitos pantallas ese niño no
interactúa con todo su entorno no
interactúa con el padre o la madre y
sólo de una pantalla y acá hay unas
niñas que se están sacando la selphy y
quizás no están atentas a todo lo que
sucede alrededor porque lo único que
importa es esa foto hay una comediante
española que dijo algo que es la verdad
para mí fantástico una buena amiga es la
que saca la selphy tantas veces como sea
necesario y que salgan bien las dos
es importante no mira la amistad
acá les traigo un supermercado bueno es
un pedacito es una góndola
todo lo que ustedes vean es producto
deseo estoy segura porque más de uno
debe querer sacarse la misma foto que un
ídolo o con una estrella y más de uno
debe estar adoptando la misma postura de
qué es lo que se pone o qué es lo que
viste o qué es lo que usa en función del
tiempo uso primero dónde está la
tendencia y dónde no
entonces si leen la pregunta pero yo les
pongo ahí por ejemplo cuántos puestos
móviles vale tu vida
las zapatillas que usan cuantos datos
móviles varias
todas las obras se están para sacar la
foto al plato de comida que se están por
comer cuántos datos listos datos perdón
les vale
se han pensado me gustaría que piensen
bueno
lomé o bien por favor
esto es una síntesis muy brutal yo lo sé
y no es que esté en contra de las redes
sociales porque las usó muchísimo y
estoy muy a favor de un buen uso de
ellas
básicamente somos rehenes de nuestra
propia virtualidad hay un deseo y una
necesidad tremenda de pensar cuántas
veces voy a ponerme las cosas o no en
función de la foto que voy a mostrar
cómo es el muro mío cómo se ve cómo son
mis perfiles quién lo va a ver hay todo
un armado muy complejo de una imagen que
es virtual y que generalmente no es
correlativa con la realidad entonces
vendemos un perfil que no es sincero que
no es genuino
porque hay tanto deseo vivir una
fantasía y no la realidad
básicamente esta situación elimina el
aura de las personas cuando llegó la
hora no me opongo en mi chica
simplemente les estoy diciendo que lo
que los hace únicos y genuinos se va
perdiendo son parte de este estándar que
se está comercializando virtualmente y
que se va a traducir en un comercio
monetario
[Música]
yo creo que la creatividad es muy camino
para que ustedes puedan explorar su
propia genialidad
para ser creativos necesitamos
contemplar necesitamos espacio de
silencio y espacio para poder entender
lo que nos está transcurriendo alrededor
la creatividad no va a emerger nunca a
menos que tengamos un momento de
aburrimiento cuando ustedes se pueden
aburrir y ser la posibilidad de
experimentarla para poder empezar a
pensar un montón de cosas que quizás no
tocaron nunca
o quizás sí y las retoma y le da una
vuelta de tuerca
la creatividad es una forma es un medio
para tener una persona que sea más
única de alguna forma más no quiero
decir genuina pero sé original y que sí
sepa quién es y que no se deje llevar
por las corrientes simplemente por una
idea de modas o de estándares y que
pueda sobrellevar un montón de cosas más
que tengan que ver con quién es y que no
sea vulnerable a cualquier producto que
te quieran vender
esta última filmina que les pongo por
libres somos se os pregunto por qué me
lo pregunte a mí misma fueron libres hoy
de que mi teléfono no me condicione
cuando se corta wifi porque se cortó la
luz o por lo que haya pasado hay como el
pánico generalizado
todo el mundo busca el teléfono y
empieza a ver cuánta batería que queda
especula las actividades que le quedan
hacer en función de esa batería y mira
sí o sí si el pack de datos está activo
y lo primero que hacen es avisar a quien
tenía que avisar que había un problema
técnico que no es revisar todas las
redes sociales para ver si no había una
notificación importante si está pasando
ojo
básicamente lo que yo les digo es
perdimos la capacidad de asombro porque
lo vimos todo una y mil veces
tenemos dormida la curiosidad
porque la fascinación por las pantallas
nos tiene totalmente omni huila 2 no
estamos viendo y la creatividad no es no
emerge porque no hay tiempo para
aburrirnos siempre tenemos actividades
siempre podemos superponer un montón de
actividades
acaba mi final espero que les guste la
creatividad nos de ustedes el
sentimiento de sentirnos más genuinos
más capaces y motivados si nos sentimos
de esta manera es porque somos personas
mucho más libres que el resto gracias
[Aplausos]